[Aplausos]
en 1987
el parlamento vasco me encarga que cree
un centro de investigación por la paz y
tratamiento de conflictos en bernie acá
le pongo de nombre gernika gogoratuz que
en euskera significa recordando a través
del corazón gernika y lo dirijo 14 años
de logros y fracasos y en los que me voy
gradualmente dando cuenta de que la paz
es débil
es un desastre de debilidad
y cómo
bien sencillo todos queremos la taza
pero queremos otras cosas más que a la
paz y esas cosas que hacen que nos
enfrentemos unos con otros
y de ahí resulta que nos armemos que que
me nacemos con guerras y que las hagamos
y los estamos haciendo nos estamos
haciendo sin darnos cuenta
cuántos de nosotros sabemos cuántas
guerras estamos haciendo hoy 7 10
cuántos hacemos oficialmente cuántas
hacemos en oficialmente cuánto matamos
con drones cada día cada minuto
no se sale pero
lo que sabemos es que el ejército más
destructor de la tierra mucho más que el
resto juntos tiene comandante como
comandante supremo alguien que ostenta
el premio nobel de la paz
pasamos a un día aciago
11 de marzo 2004 el día en que revientan
los trenes por es por atentados
terroristas el día que se rompe en
sueños se rompen vidas día de inmenso
dolor
en madrid
encuentro
a los afectados y al grupo que se ha
juntado para apoyar a los afectados
y compartimos
inquietudes
y también en la fans de cómo hacer que
la voluntad de paz tenga más fuerza
esa inquietud la trasladamos
a media la prados y comparte ese afán y
allí generamos
un grupo muy variopinto de más de 50
que pone en marcha el año 2011 un
proyecto
y el proyecto consiste
en coleccionar
y hacer públicos relatos
con hebras de paz vida
eso no lo tiene nadie
[Risas]
y eso qué es
como hebras de paz viva o eras
entendemos
actos
acciones generosas desinteresadas
de ayudar a alguien en grave peligro o
en una situación de abuso intolerable
por verse como parte de un grupo enemigo
o de un grupo extraño
además acciones insumisas que rompen la
disciplina
y
la sumisión que se pone desde el grupo
con nuestra
acciones
que a primera vista parecen extrañas
raras sobrenaturales de héroes de gente
excepcional
e insensatas
pero que según los vamos buscando y
encontrando vemos que son hechas por
gente que se entiende como común y
corriente que es gente normal que no
entiende pero ninguna heroicidad sino
simplemente que ha hecho lo que le
tocaba hacer
y nos damos cuenta de que la razón de
que no se encuentren es que no se busca
entonces estamos recogiendo esos relatos
los recogemos porque hay algunos muchos
y a publicados chequeados
y en relatos seguros
pero la mayoría de los relatos no los
recogemos nosotros sino con los recogen
chavales
alumnos de institutos entre el 11 y 17
años
que con ayuda de sus profesores y con la
complicidad de sus familias
charlan sobre surf
los mayores de su familia o de su
confianza
al sí
el abuelo de un alumno
le regala un relato su padre al comienzo
de la guerra se encuentra en la zona
republicana pero su familia está en la
zona de francos y quiere cruzar el
frente ponerse con su familia de sherman
y al intentar hacerlo se encuentra con
un miliciano de guardia armado
precisamente con la orden de impedir que
lo haga
se pies y se queda rígido se miran uno a
otro no hablan para nada y el miliciano
en vez de apuntarle con el fusil le hace
un gesto tranquilizador con la mano de
que pase pase y cambia su vida
ahora aterrizamos
en berlín
para mostrar cómo vamos adquiriendo la
capacidad de ver es de ver esas esas
obras en la vida diaria a nuestro
alrededor
hace unos meses en berlin a las 11 de la
noche con una estación de metro entré a
un grupo de muchachos media docena
bebidos
britton es como con pinta de skinheads
en un vagón y se encuentra que hay una
señora mayor sentada y algunos metros
día un muchacho negro
enseguida se encienden y empiezan a
provocarle con gestos y muecas y gritos
algo va a pasar pero lo que pasa es no
lo que pensamos sino que la buena mujer
se levanta de su asiento y se va a
poquito un poquito y se siente al lado
del muchacho negro y se pone a hablar
con él como si tal cosa
y eso descoloca al grupo
bajan la voz y se bajan en la próxima
estación
no ha pasado nada pero de una forma
sutil
esa mujer ha librado al muchacho negro
de una bestial paliza
todos los pueblos tenemos pasados
traumáticos
entonces recogemos relatos de guatemala
bajo ríos montt
de argentina con la junta
del holocausto de palestina en muchos
tiempos
de la antigua yugoslavia
siria si tenemos relatos cecilia de hoy
memoria del presente
cojamos estos relatos les chequeamos y
corregimos algún fallo que puede que
tengan y tienen a veces
y luego les pasamos a un formato
adecuado para que se presenten en
público entonces pero terminamos con
ellos desde la intimidad de las familias
que callaban esos relatos hasta que se
hagan públicos
y
vamos a hacerlos públicos aquí ahora
pero en octubre a mediados de octubre en
bruselas en polonia
en diciembre enero el donosti
y en nuestra página web
y qué tienen que ver estos relatos con
la voluntad de paz
se alimenta de la memoria pero no de
cualquier memoria sino de lo que los
expertos llaman la memoria colectiva
qué es una memoria que arrastra de las
voluntades
y esa memoria tiene tres rasgos uno
es selectiva 2 es cerrada
y tres es amarga y negra
selectiva porque el pasado que vivieron
nuestros mayores recoge los trozos que
hablan bien del propio grupo
que aparece como humano
víctima inocente heroico
en contraste con todos los otros grupos
que aparecen como culpables
causantes del trauma vivido
traidores cobardes
alemanas faltos de humanidad inhumanos
son memorias que rechazan los relatos
del otro brindan los propios
y que además venga
el pasado por las gafas de la justicia
penal y la justicia penal entiende de
delito de crimen de dolor de
arrepentimiento de castigo de culpa
y poco más
el resto son mate no antes
hay una memoria que educa para la paz
otra que impulsa la guerra y a veces ni
se sabe
es que en memoria está promoviendo ok
pero tienen muchísima fuerza fijaros por
ejemplo
qué es lo que origina la segunda guerra
mundial
la memoria colectiva que construye la
alemania nazi de la de la derrota
humillante que sufrió en la primera
guerra mundial
sin la memoria de esa derrota no se
desencadena la segunda guerra mundial y
la memoria
que alimenta la paz
es más débil que el alcalá que alimenta
la guerra porque la alimenta la que
alimenta la guerra lo hace a tope
pero la que alimenta la paz y lo hace a
medias porque la paz es más de lo que
nosotros creemos no es la paz
como definen los expertos la paz
negativa que es la paz del no a la
guerra y a la violencia es decir que no
a la guerra ya la violencia
señalaré un pasado y decir nunca más
así está toda europa llena de monumentos
a los caídos resaltan de la matriz de
cementerios
de antiguos campos de concentración
gritando todos nunca más fuera de ese
pasado
pero la paz no solo es la paz del nunca
más sino que la paz es mucho más
y lo que los expertos llaman la paz
positiva y nosotros llamamos la paz vida
que es la memoria
d
nuestra necesidad y nuestros actos de
convivencia que es la paz vida
estamos inmersos en esa paz de
convivencia
la vida no nos la damos nosotros sino
que nos la dan otras vidas
y nuestra vida alberga sus primeros
meses antes del nacimiento en el cuerpo
de una mujer y ya eso es convivencia y
la convivencia estamos toda nuestra vida
diaria pues sabemos que esta convivencia
y contamos con ella anteayer que he
venido en tren desde desde donosti he
cogido el metro con la maleta y según
y va subiendo las escaleras de piedra
234 personas que iban bajando han venido
con una sonrisa así alegre ayudaron a
subir la maleta imaginaros si me llegó a
caer
eso es tan evidente que nos olvidamos de
ellos es demasiado simple para
conceptualizar lo lo que ocurre es que
al construir las memorias colectivas
como ya he dicho se queda descartado
y esas memorias
y colectivas
tan poderosas y tan controladoras de la
voluntad
nos presentan esa construcción del
pasado amargo pero
y oscuro si entonces metemos allí
relatos con hebras de paz vida
metemos una lucecita que
y hace que aparezca es en ese pasado
un paisaje
alegre a menos atrayente un pasado que
no solo denuncia el pasado sino que
anuncia el futuro
paz negativa
atiende a nuestra necesidad de seguridad
y de justicia y es el alimento base de
la memoria al alimento amargo y oscuro
las pequeñas dosis de hebras de paz vida
son el afrodisíaco que añadimos hacer a
ese alimento y así sale una mezcla
maravillosa
y una fuerza
la fuerza que la voluntad de paz
necesita
para pasar de un mundo en guerra a un
mundo que está arrinconando la guerra
muchos de vosotros que me veis mejor a
mí que yo a vosotros pero ya veo que
estáis empezando a pensar eso pasará mi
familia eso ha pasado con mi tía o con
este cuñado así es raro que no conocemos
mucho de sus vidas
entonces estáis empezando a encontrar en
el pasado
tesoros escondidos
pues igual me pasó a mí
cuando yo tenía cuatro años
un taxista republicano echó una hebra de
padre vida a mi padre
a unos kilómetros de aquí y le salvó la
vida
es un recuerdo una joya que quedó
enterrada en la memoria familiar nos ha
comentado
pero 48 años después
mueren mi padre
y el día que mi padre muere hay una
llamada de teléfono
y dice yo soy la viuda del taxista que
salvó la vida de su padre
que ha muerto en rusia que tuvo que
mirar
ella ha desenterrado ese tesoro
escondido
y me lo ha regalado y yo ahora lo estoy
haciendo público
estoy rompiendo una ley de muy callada
de mi familia de que estas cosas no se
comentan y estoy comentando y me lo van
a agradecer
así que ahora os puedo pasar la pelota
porque vosotros también tenéis vuestra
tierra y no está que es el pasado en la
que hay tesoros escondidos
pero pasó la pelota de un campo de juego
al otro campo del juego y si tenéis
relatos de eso si queréis maldad nos los
nuestra ya hicieron muy fácil
gracias
[Aplausos]